hello everyone welcome to the internet
and my name is
today we're going to look at the
differences between chinese and
chinese well what i mean is we'll be
looking at
two of the many chinese languages
mandarin and
cantonese as i mentioned in my video on
chinese
chinese is not a single language but
rather a number of dialect
groups that are united by a common
writing system
the spoken languages are different and
generally mutually unintelligible which
is definitely the case with mandarin and
cantonese
which are both synthetic languages or
chinese languages spoken in china
mandarin is spoken by 960 million native
speakers
mainly in the north of china but is now
used all over mainland
china and taiwan as the official
language of government media and
education
and it's one of the four official
languages of singapore as well
cantonese on the other hand is spoken by
50 to 60 million native speakers in hong
kong macau
guanzo and some adjacent areas as well
as in chinese diaspora communities
around the world
it's part of the wider ua branch of
chinese
before we get into the main differences
between the two languages it's important
to point out that these days
speakers of either language typically
write in standard chinese
or which is based on the beijing dialect
of mandarin
but when cantonese speakers read
standard chinese they say each word
using cantonese pronunciation which
creates the misconception that cantonese
is exactly the same as mandarin except
for the pronunciation but that's not the
case
spoken cantonese is also somewhat
different in terms of grammar and
vocabulary
and there's also written vernacular
cantonese which reflects the spoken
language
and is used in some informal contexts
the differences we talk about in this
video will be based on spoken cantonese
and its written equivalent written
vernacular cantonese
by far the largest difference between
mandarin and cantonese lies in
pronunciation
both of these languages are tonal
languages but they each have a different
number of tones
mandarin has four tones plus one neutral
tone there's a high flat tone
a rising tone a falling rising tone
a falling tone and the neutral tone for
example
the neutral tone is a short
de-emphasized syllable which is said
with no regard to tone
cantonese has six basic tones there's a
high flat tone
a mid rising tone a mid flat tone a low
falling tone
a low rising tone and a low flat tone
c c c
c c c
some people count three additional tones
for a total of nine
these are historical tones that were
used for syllables ending in
in standard cantonese they've merged
with other tones so that the only
remainder of these tones is the stop
consonant at the end of the syllable
so if we compare the two sets of tones
you'll see that mandarin has a tone that
falls then rises
which is something that cantonese
doesn't have you'll also notice that
mandarin has a narrower range of tones
cantonese has a wider range of tones
with tones essentially in two ranges
the mid to high range and the low range
this makes cantonese harder for english
speakers to learn than mandarin
because instead of distinguishing only
the movement of a tone
they also have to distinguish whether a
tone is in the mid to high range or the
low range
in both mandarin and cantonese and all
chinese languages for that matter
each chinese character or
represents one morpheme either a word or
a meaningful part of a word
which can't be further divided but each
character is pronounced differently in
mandarin and cantonese
one example of this is the word for i in
mandarin it's pronounced
with the third tone or falling rising
tone while in cantonese it's pronounced
with the fifth tone or low rising tone
so the tone is different but also notice
that the initial consonant sound is
different as well
another example is this word which means
china in mandarin it's pronounced
with a high flat tone and a rising tone
and in cantonese it's pronounced
with a high flat tone and a mid-flat
tone
the pronunciation of these two words
might sound pretty close
but the tones are partially different
and remember that the meaning of words
is partly determined by tones
notice that the second character is
pronounced with a k
sound at the end in cantonese while in
mandarin it ends in a vowel sound
in mandarin every syllable ends in a
vowel or in a nasal sound
in cantonese however syllables can end
in the stop consonants
po as well pronunciation differences
between mandarin and cantonese are often
consistent
this character that we just looked at is
pronounced
in mandarin and so is this character and
this one
among many others in cantonese they're
all pronounced
the difference here lies mainly in the
initial consonant sound
the systems of romanization are
different from mandarin and cantonese
so the roman characters might be a
little misleading here
but the initial consonant in mandarin is
something like the english
j sound but with your tongue curled back
the initial consonant in cantonese is
like ts in english think of the end of
the word cats
let's look at three more characters
first in mandarin
and in cantonese
in this case we can see that the
consonants and vowels consistently
correspond
but that a different tone in mandarin
corresponds to a different tone in
cantonese
but the sounds don't always correspond
like this there are also characters that
have the same pronunciation in one
language but different pronunciations in
the other
in mandarin there's see
but in cantonese they're pronounced
here we can see that the mandarin sounds
don't consistently correspond
with cantonese sounds in mandarin
they're pronounced the same except for
the tones
but the three words are pronounced in
three completely different ways in
cantonese
differences in grammar both languages
are fundamentally
svo for example here's a sentence
meaning i read those books first in
mandarin
next in cantonese
word for word both sentences translate
as i
read those book so you can see that both
are svo
subject verb object even though the
words are different
in both languages the verb consists of
two parts the verb itself
followed by the perfective marker which
shows completion
and in both languages the object
includes two parts
a determiner followed by the noun a
determiner is a word like an article or
a demonstrative adjective which tells us
information about which noun we're
talking about
one difference can be noted in sentences
that have a direct
object in basic sentences in mandarin
the indirect object
comes before the direct object while in
cantonese it comes after
for example here's a sentence in each
language meaning give me a pen
in mandarin we would say
and in cantonese it's
notice that these are imperative
sentences commands or instructions
word for word the mandarin sentence
translates as give
me appen the cantonese sentence
translates as
give appen me with the indirect object
in the sentence final position
after the direct object notice that the
word meaning i
and the phrase meaning appen are
reversed
let's take a look at the phrase meaning
appen for a second
it consists of three parts first the
word meaning
one followed by a word that functions as
a counter for long cylindrical objects
and then the word for pen in other cases
the indirect object is in the same
position as in mandarin
before the direct object like in this
sentence meaning
he sends me a book in mandarin it's
tasoo
and in cantonese
notice right here that in both sentences
the indirect object comes after the verb
and before the direct object in both
languages the indirect object could go
after the direct object
but another word functioning like a
preposition meaning two
would be necessary another difference is
the way that comparisons are formed in
mandarin and cantonese
here's a sentence meaning i'm bigger
than you in mandarin you'd say
while in cantonese you'd say
word for word the mandarin sentence is i
compare
you big or you could think of it as i
compared to you and big the cantonese
sentence translates as
i big more than you so you can see that
in the mandarin sentence the adjective
comes at the end
while in the cantonese sentence it comes
before the comparative word and the
pronoun meaning you
notice that the comparative word is
different in the two languages
differences in vocabulary in chinese
languages
words are represented by ideographic
characters called hanzu
sometimes mandarin and cantonese use
different words represented by different
chinese characters to represent the same
concept and in other cases the same
chinese character might have a somewhat
different meaning or usage in either
language
the difference in vocabulary could be as
high as 50 percent
that's when comparing mandarin to spoken
cantonese and written vernacular
cantonese
here are some examples of different
vocabulary these words function as
copula verbs
like is in english is used in mandarin
when read in cantonese it's pronounced
si
but the typical cantonese word is hai
this character is also used in mandarin
and is pronounced
shi but it's used with the basic meaning
of relation or connection
these are negation words meaning no or
not in mandarin it's
again this word is also used in
cantonese and pronounced
but but it's used more often in standard
writing than the colloquial cantonese
word
this word is not used in mandarin if we
look at the word for teacher
in both languages we'll see that
mandarin uses the word
while cantonese uses the word
this word is also used in cantonese with
the pronunciation
losi this word is also used in mandarin
with the pronunciation
and means mister or husband actually in
cantonese it has both of those meanings
as well as the meaning of teacher
but from what i hear this word sinsang
is not
used by younger people who use law c
instead
for the meaning of teacher these are the
words for bus
in mandarin it's
these four characters could be
translated literally as something like
public shared gas car but normally these
two characters form the word meaning
public
and these two form the word meaning car
in cantonese it's
asi a word derived from the english word
bus
two chinese characters with sounds
similar to those of the word bus
were chosen to represent this english
borrowing this type of borrowing from
english is more common in cantonese
particularly in the hong kong variety
because it was a dependent territory of
the uk in mandarin to ask someone's name
you would say
in cantonese you would say like you
might yeah man
here you can see that the word order is
the same so the sentences are
translatable word for word
if we translate word for word we get you
call
what name but some of the words are
different the word for what is different
and the word for name or first name is
different in mandarin it's a two
character compound word
and in cantonese it's a single character
of course even the words that are the
same are pronounced differently in
either language
this word meaning you is pronounced in
mandarin as
knee with a falling rising tone in
cantonese it's
lay with a low rising tone you may have
noticed that the cantonese audio
recording sounded more like
lei with an initial l sound rather than
nay with an initial n sound the n sound
is considered
proper cantonese while the l sound is
considered
casual or relaxed pronunciation
this word meaning call is pronounced in
mandarin as
ciao with a falling tone in cantonese
it's
keel with a mid flat tone this word or
word component
meaning name is pronounced in mandarin
as ming
with a rising tone and in cantonese it's
man with a mid-rising tone
note that throughout this video i've
been using traditional chinese
characters for both mandarin and
cantonese
but in mainland china singapore and
malaysia simplified chinese characters
are used for mandarin
while traditional characters are used in
taiwan as for cantonese in hong kong and
macau
traditional characters are used in
guangzhou and surrounding areas
people normally use simplified
characters for cantonese some people
think that mandarin is always written in
simplified characters and that cantonese
is always written in traditional
characters
but it's not that simple you may be
asking yourself which language is better
to learn well there are definite
benefits to learning either one
if you learn mandarin you'll be
understood all over mainland china
as well as taiwan and also in singapore
and malaysia
but they'll probably just speak english
to you and if you learn cantonese you'll
be able to communicate with people in
the southern part of mainland china as
well as hong kong and macau and you'll
be able to enjoy all of those famous
movies from hong kong
either way if you have a deep cultural
interest in either of these languages
that will certainly make it easier to
learn
the question of the day for native
speakers of either mandarin or cantonese
to what extent can you understand the
other language when it's spoken
how about when it's written and for
learners of either language
have you taken a look at the other
language what similarities and
differences did you notice
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and
instagram and i'm not sure if you can
follow those in china but
please try and once again i would like
to say thank you to all of my wonderful
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here on the screen
they are my top tier patreon supporters
so many thanks to them
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you